life is awesome we're very lucky
whatever you're stressed about right now
is something that is not that big of a
deal if you're lucky enough to have
health and the people that you love have
health like everything is manageable
even if you're frustrated with the job
right now or client or a situation it's
all manageable it's not the kind of
things you're going to worry about when
you're
I spend a lot of time with 70 80 and 90
year old people that are not my
relatives and I can tell you something
that happens if you hang out with 90
year old strangers they don't talk about
things that we worry about day to day
they talk about very macro things love
spending more time with family but
enjoyed and so you know be very grateful
we're all fortunate to live in this time
where people live longer a lot of
blessings ahead of you take a deep
breath you can control it you can fix it
it's not that big of a deal so that's
the mindset